I think I think everybody needs therapy
so I think anybody was dealing with
stress or a fear can should at least try
it it's like saying you don't want sushi
we've never had the feeling that we're
gonna tap on today is your concern about
having an out-of-body like losing
control of your body yeah the one that's
coming to mind is the roller coaster
whine it's my Wonderland yeah and I'm on
the mind buster okay and it's a it's a
it's a bigger roller coaster and just
feeling out of control and fighting the
coaster instead of enjoying it so what
would I have to go on the mind buster
again it's like is that the end result
it like is that me that's a great idea
okay this is a friend of mine Crona she
came to my workshop in September and I
have an issue with being out of control
of my body and so she is an expert what
do you what did you win your next bin so
many things what are you an expert
she's an expert in lots of stuff so
we're gonna flip the script today or I'm
gonna be the subject instead of the
other way around I'm gonna be the
student and she's gonna teach me so I'm
going to Tony Robbins event in November
and I shared in my email to you guys
that I am afraid of being out of control
of my body I've never been drunk ever
I've never done any kind of what are the
drugs substances nothing I hate roller
coasters I fight them I fight the roller
coasters so they don't like being out of
control of my body
and so I sent that and I said you know
last time when I went to Tony Robbins
event I feel like I didn't give all of
myself because I was fighting the loss
of control and then Crona emailed me and
said hey I have some techniques that can
help you and I want to walk you through
them so we're here we're gonna walk
through them and is there anything you
want to say before we we start the
techniques yeah so there are a lot of
different techniques you can use for
today we're going to use just one and
it's called emotional freedom technique
there's other many other different types
of therapies right there's cognitive
behavioral therapy there's dialectic
behavioral therapy but today we're doing
this one emotional freedom technique and
there's lots of benefits to that so
first of all one of the benefits is that
you can do it yourself so I'm going to
teach you today and anybody watching you
can learn this
and it's easy to learn and really what's
important is you get on the pressure
points so that's what's important to pay
attention to okay and then we're gonna
be saying words that go along with that
but even if you can't think of the words
that's okay even doing the motion that
we're doing helps reduce anxiety it
reduces stress and tension and it will
reduce symptoms of depression or sadness
would you need anything for me yeah so
other than that let's get started
Emma's ready ready okay so first of all
the feeling that we're gonna tap on
today is your concern about having an
out-of-body like losing control of your
body yeah yeah so can you tell me a
bedtime when that first when you first
had that feeling or that experience
probably being afraid of heights like
looking down and feeling like I can't
like I don't want to fall okay but the
most the most that's probably happened
earlier but the one that's coming to
mind is the roller coaster one okay so
my Wonderland yeah and I'm on the mind
buster okay
and it's a it's a it's a bigger roller
coaster okay I'm just feeling out of
control okay and fighting the coaster
instead of enjoying it I'll still fight
the other roller coasters but I can like
the kiddie roller coasters or like they
have bars right like a 4/5 I'll fight
the little ones and I can because
they're going so that I can still fight
them I don't have to okay I don't have
to give up control so you go on little
kiddie roller coasters well I go go with
my son
I don't like rides period okay yeah like
let's go on roller coasters like no no
interesting but when my son wants to go
I'll go with him on the the kiddie way
no he's not just starting to get into
bigger ones
so you face your fear for him yes it's
more discomfort it's not a finger
because I know I can handle those ones
okay but if you said go on the mind
buster with me right like you go into my
investor I don't wanna go into my
investor okay
so besides rollercoasters and Europe
Heights anything else kind of connected
with that well I mentioned like I've
never been drunk yes I just see people I
remember being in Germany and
Oktoberfest and everybody's hammered and
this guy is just like drunk and ends up
walking right into a pole I don't want
that I don't want that to be me not not
for like embarrassment I just don't like
the I want to be out of control of my
body same thing I've never even tried
drugs I don't know why I guess it wasn't
in mind it wasn't in my circle although
my dad smoked a little bit growing up
but I never I haven't tried a cigarette
I haven't tried anything so if you had
to rate it right now when you think
about it yeah I want you to think about
your roller coaster if you had to rate
at zero to ten zero being I have no
feelings at all no concerns at all about
riding the roller coaster okay good mind
buster okay you go eight okay and ten
being oh my god I'm petrified
you're gonna go eight yeah we'll see
what the other questions go but Elvis
start with eight okay so then we're
gonna tap on acupressure points so there
this is important so we're gonna use ten
acupressure points and there's different
varieties out there so if people are
googling it there there's people
more acupressure points but so we're
gonna start right here this is called
the karate chop and you want to tap like
that right yep and the other thing is so
when when we're tapping there's kind of
different strengths of tapping right so
we can tap gently you can shop a lot and
we're in between that right so you want
to feel it okay
doesn't matter which hand either hand
nope doesn't matter which hand you can
switch it up okay so that's the karate
chop point so what so I'm I am I doing
this like when I'm on the roller coaster
no okay yeah okay I suppose yeah okay so
what we're gonna have to go on the mind
Buster again it's like is that the end
result it's like I think that's a great
idea
make sure to video what I want to see it
so in the actual session itself we're
going to do what's called the basic
recipe for the emotional freedom
technique and if you google emotional
freedom technique the founder is Gary
Craig and it's also called tapping so
you might see that if you look it up so
what the purpose of that is is to use
your acupuncture points but we don't use
needles so it's acupressure and that
combined with psychology is the
emotional freedom technique so we used
10 points so the karate chop eyebrows
side of eyes beneath the eyes meet the
nose
beneath the lower lip each side of the
sternum underarm and under the ribcage
and then the top of the head and those
pressure points were used to tap on in
regards to addressing Evans fear of
being out of control of his body I don't
want to hold on to this fear anymore I
don't want to hold on to this fear
anymore let it go let it go let it go I
don't want this fear anymore I don't
want this here anymore
okay I'm tuned to the top I'm open to
letting this go now I'm open to letting
this go now open to letting all of these
feelings go now I'm open to letting all
of these fears go now breath in release
it out another deep breath in and then
out okay zero to ten how do you feel
about getting sick number five okay
any thoughts come to mind I'm thinking
how do I I want to do something this is
natural like I want to challenge it so
what's my next step to challenge it like
I want to jump off then go get drunk
with Brahimi or Crona told me to get
disclaimer we finished the exercise and
it went pretty well Evan started at
about an eight when he thought of being
on the mind Buster rollercoaster ride at
Canada's Wonderland and he went down to
a five there was a little bit of
resistance with Evan in the fact that he
used distraction I think as a way to you
know he was doing a lot of planning and
he certainly was in his head
and it's helpful in doing that therapy
to be more present and more in your body
and in the
so if I was doing that again with Evan I
would probably do a mindfulness exercise
before we started and really focus on
getting Evan to be present and right
here right now in the moment to help him
when he's doing the emotional freedom
technique for it to be more effective I
didn't have expectations going in I
think that was what the greatest part
was like my expectations was to spend an
hour with an awesome person and learn
someone for knowledge but I didn't want
to know what I was what I'd be doing
going in like don't prep me don't tell
me anything whatever you need to tell
the audience awesome but like I don't
want to know I think because I overthink
things and because I'm like so strategic
I don't want to know so that we actually
get a genuine reaction because he told
me we're gonna do tapping an arm test
and like stuff like that be like oh yeah
and then I would start judging it
immediately right so it's like it's
great to just be in the moment right and
so that's something that is similar to
being out of control your body's mean in
the moment and so my strategy to trick
myself to do it is to not have any prep
which used to scare me like I would
always want to have the interview
questions in advance and now I was like
no I don't want a single one in advance
because it actually makes for a better
interview I think it's awesome how much
of what we do is similar I just do it
for a different audience and you're
trained and you have all the words and
you're doing this day in day out and I'm
doing my own weird form of it helping
entrepreneurs and I think I think any
form of self awareness any form of
positive therapy is good whether you get
that like whether you can do it to
yourself or whether you watch videos or
whether you go see a therapist or
whether you're doing meditation or like
what yeah it's great
that was why I wanted to do this just
weather what like this might be the best
thing of all time feet like if if
anything you saw was interesting and
like go try it's not that hard
you have the exercises do it to yourself
take the thing that you're afraid of
like what's the worst case scenario
you're gonna like you said there's no
harm if you start ten minutes sitting
there and tap it on the ten points and
saying I want to release this fear and
then see how you feel and if going from
an 8 to a 5 is beneficial then then give
it a shot so I think anybody who's
dealing with stress or a fear and should
at least try it it's like saying you
don't want sushi we've never had sushi I
say to everything you need to try it
twice
everything you should try it twice
giving yourself a one time to try
something you know I think that's not
really a kind of a fair shake with
anything so ever you're gonna try
anything I always say I tried twice see
I try once but have no judgment on
myself for what happened like the
results don't matter because you never
know right if you had an off day or if
you know there were different
circumstances or whatever you know so
with anything that I ever try I would
say try twice but then it limits how
much you can do by half you can't try
new things you're gonna give it all the
first time and then you give it all the
second time but then you can try as many
things oh because you're doing it
everything twice instead of more things
once that's true most people are trying
enough period anyway I like to say yes
almost anything as long as it's not
hurting somebody Yeah right
[Music]
but most things don't people go there by
default like well why don't we did they
like to pick the worst thing of all time
like of course you're not gonna go do
that but there's like 99% of other
things that you should be doing they
should try at least once just to see if
it's for you or not so I think I think I
think everybody needs therapy I would
100% agree with that everybody needs
therapy I think everybody I think
there's there's no drawback to going to
talk to somebody who has solely your
best interest that hurt and isn't taking
anybody's side and with family members
they're wonderful a lot of times yeah
and and they love you they care about
you maybe it depends on who your family
is but and best friends and things like
that but in the end they still have a
vested interest in the decisions that
you make
you're still impacting them based on
what you do so they're their support of
you is alway and their advice to you or
their encouragement or it's it's a
little bit slanted because they have a
certain desired outcome for you and a
therapist doesn't the therapist says
what do you want your outcome to be and
how can I help you get there and that's
very different perspective at least once
you go try it twice
we're not that scary cool thank you for
coming in thank you for all your love
and help me and like Crona reached out
to me I mean I said I guess I sent the
email out to everybody but Crona said
hey I have a tool that might help you
and I appreciate all the love if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would become like a little beacon
if you want more from crowing I took
that the becoming video we did where we
talked about parenting I think you'll
enjoy it the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there one of the best things you can do
is also show your failures and your
struggles and
not just my one and try to hide it from
them